We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P. this
voicemail is a reminder about why, uh, what
is, it is a reminder of many things.
This is a reminder about why we're not going
to win by arguing with Trumpists.
Okay, let me just leave it at that and we'll
listen to it.
Yes.
I just want to know you're watching the same
impeachment and queries than I am because
ah, I don't know.
Y'all don't understand nothing.
I was a Democrat.
Now I'm a Republican because of the way the
Democrats have acted and done to this country,
taking money from social security and everything
else.
And y'all are then after president Trump ever
since he became president.
And I think it's a shame.
It's pitiful.
I have a good day.
Yeah.
So that's why just arguing with people and
trying to convince folks like that.
It, it, it just can't be a strategy.
And we have sort of a followup voicemail to
that coming up on tomorrow's program that
I think you will also find equally disturbing
if you are concerned with the truth and facts
and understanding things as they are rather
than as you would wish them to be.
But that's a perfect example of why we, we,
we just need to get the vote out and convincing
people like that to change their mind.
It's not going to happen.
All right.
We've got a great bonus show coming up for
you.
We will talk about the four women Joe Biden
says he would consider as running mates.
We will talk about the struggles of the milk
industry.
We will talk about has Lez new cyber truck
and I will disclose share ownership.
No, I'm not doing that anymore.
Uh, but I do.
Um, and of course remember that on black Friday
we will have a huge David Pakman show membership
special to be notified of that.
Just become a subscriber to the newsletter
by signing up at David [inaudible],
pacman.com and on black Friday, you will have
that very exciting membership discount code
in your email.
I'll speak to you on the bonus show in just
a minute.
The David Pakman show@davidpakman.com [inaudible].